you spent nearly half a century in the
House of Commons how do you think the
mess that your party finds itself in now
compared to the last 50 years oh I've
seen nothing like this it's quite you
can make some comparisons with the late
1970s you can make I suppose a few
comparisons with the major government
where we didn't really have a majority
by the time we finished but the the
background to all the problems we have
with brixey the economy changing demands
on the public services though nothing
like this at all that is quite unique
although most of the Western democracies
are having exactly the same thing and
elections like President Trump
president mackerel show that the
traditional political system is under
huge strain in other countries as well